a theater has a total of 63 seats in a
rectangular grid here they are right
over here
it currently has nine rows each with an
equal number of seats we see that one
two three four five six seven eight nine
rows
how many total seats will it have if it
adds two seats per row so how many
total seats will it have if it adds two
seats per row so we want to figure out
is the total number of seats so let's
say that the total
the total
is going to be equal to the number of
seats that the theater already has and
they tell us that they have 63 seats in
a rectangular grid so it's going to be
63 seats plus the new seats plus however
many it adds so plus
plus
the new seats well what are the new
seats going to be well the new seats are
going to be i have nine rows and i'm
adding two seats per row so the new
seats are going to be nine rows times
two seats per row so we could say that
the total
we could say that the total is going to
be equal to
plus
9 times 2 and we'll talk more about
order of operations but clearly in this
situation we want to multiply 9 times 2
to figure out the total new number of
seats and then we want to add that to 63
and if we just write it like this
multiplication takes
you will always do multiplication and
when you just see it in a row like this
you'll do the multiplication before you
do the addition so this is literally
saying hey multiply 9 times 2 first then
add to 63 which is exactly what we care
about and what is 9 times 2 let's add
those two seats per row so that's 2
and
so 2 times 9 2 4 6 8 10
12 14 16 18 is 18
so we're adding 18 new seats so let me
write this down i covered up my old
total so total
is equal to 63
plus 18
plus 18 i had 63 seats i'm now adding 18
seats so total my total number of seats
is now going to be 63 plus 18. let's see
8 plus 3 is 11.
60 plus 10 is 70.
70 plus 11 is going to be i have 80 i
have 81 seats i now have 9 rows with 9
seats each which gets me 81 total